es ist tatsächlich eine parallelwelt im
untergrund sogar noch kilometer tief
unter der erde wimmelte es von viren
pilzen und bakterien und zwar in
riesigen mengen das ist absolut
spektakulär doch zu dieser wirklich mit
seriösen lebenswelt der sogenannten
tiefen biosphäre gibt es mehr fragen als
antworten handelt es sich hierbei
möglicherweise sogar um die wiege des
lebens und auch für das leben auf dem
mars liefert die unterwelt der erde
spannende hinweise klicks und future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
er nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
klicks um gibt es auch als podcast zum
beispiel für unterwegs sie links zu
spotify und apple podcasts sind unten in
der video beschreibung also ans
abonnieren denken es sind wirklich
mörderische bedingungen denn hier
kilometer tief unter der erde fehlt
wirklich alles was es eigentlich zum
leben braucht es gibt kein licht keine
organische nahrung und auch keinen
sauerstoff dennoch wimmelt es hier vom
mikrobiell im leben es sind vor allem
einfache bakterien und archaea also
einzellige lebewesen die sehr extremen
bedingungen trotzdem beispielsweise
temperaturen von 120 grad celsius
ertragen und den druck von mehr als 1200
atmosphäre von sauerstoff und der sonne
sind sie im untergrund der erde zum teil
sogar mehr als fünf kilometer entfernt
und das widerspricht allem was man lange
zeit über die existenz von leben
angenommen hatte fachleute gingen noch
bis mitte des 19 jahrhunderts davon aus
dass sowohl licht als auch sauerstoff
für die existenz von leben unerlässlich
ist doch das unterirdische leben beweist
das gegenteil selbst mehrere kilometer
tief unter der landoberfläche und unter
dem meeresgrund existieren wohl knapp
drei millionen von mikroben eine eins
mit 24 0 und gut möglich sind es sogar
noch mehr wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass die
gesamte biomasse dieser tiefen biosphäre
wie sie in der fachsprache genannt wird
die der menschheit weit übertrifft
aktuelle studien deuten darauf hin dass
unter uns leben bis zu fünf kilometer
unter der erdoberfläche und sogar bis
zehn kilometer unter dem meeresspiegel
existieren könnte
das volumen der tiefen biosphäre
entspricht somit dem doppelten inhalt
aller welt mehrere zusammen das muss man
sich mal vorstellen möglicherweise ist
auch das artenreichtum in den tiefen
schichten der erdkruste sogar noch
deutlich größer als die des
oberirdischen lebens die forschung zu
dieser lebenswelt unter der erde steckt
noch in den kinderschuhen und immer
wieder machen forscherinnen und forscher
spannende und überraschende entdeckung
und die geben nicht nur spektakuläre
indizien und hinweise für die entstehung
von leben auf der erde sondern auch für
das leben auf dem mars wie ist die
wissenschaft also zu diesem
spektakulären ergebnis gekommen
von 1920 hatten zwei wissenschaftler im
ölschlamm aus 600 meter tiefe bakterien
aufgespürt doch die fachwelt ließ das
nicht gelten denn das konnte man sich
beim besten willen nicht vorstellen also
abbruch ende aus keine forschung
jahrzehntelang erst 1985 zeigt nur es
bohrungen im untergrund das die
unterwelt der erde doch lebt die
bakterien die eindeutig lebten stammten
aus 500 metern tiefe und kontaminationen
konnten bei diesem bohrung
ausgeschlossen werden
der erste sensationelle beweis also für
das leben in der tiefe und das war nur
der anfang denn seitdem sind
forschungsteams weltweit auf der
intensiven suche danach dennoch haben
wir noch lange kein vollständiges bild
über die tiefen biosphäre und viele
viele fragen sind offen wie schaffen es
die mikroben mit diesen extremen
bedingungen umzugehen wie produzieren
sie ihre energie so ganz ohne sauerstoff
im sonnenlicht und können wir uns diese
mikroben möglicherweise sogar zu nutze
machen
fachleute gehen übrigens fest davon aus
dass es nicht nur bakterien und archaeen
sind die diese unterwelt der erde
beherbergt stattdessen könnten sogar
mehrzeller existieren
doch wie ist das leben überhaupt dorthin
gekommen auf diese frage gibt es noch
keine eindeutige antwort die meisten
fachleute gehen allerdings davon aus
dass es schon sehr früh leben im
untergrund gab möglicherweise lebten die
bakterien also schon in der kreidezeit
oder noch früher in der tiefen biosphäre
fest steht dass die meisten
mikroorganismen die dort leben den
oberirdischen mikroorganismen ähnlich
sind sind sie möglicherweise sogar mit
ihnen verwandt wurden oberirdische
kolonien verschüttet oder
das grundwasser in den tiefe gespült und
sind die kolonien dort nun für immer
eingesperrt auch meteoriteneinschläge
könnten den weg für mikroben in die
tiefen biosphäre geebnet haben ein
schwedisches forschungsteam hat dazu den
größten krater europas genauer unter die
lupe genommen
die rede ist vom silly am krater in
mittelschweden der rund 55 kilometer
groß ist und vor rund 380 millionen
jahren entstand als die fachleute das
tiefengestein genauer analysierten
fanden sie kleine kristalle aus
kalziumkarbonat und sulfid und die haben
sich durch mikrobielle aktivität
gebildet so das forschungsteam genau
genommen weiß die verteilung
verschiedener kohlenstoff und schwefel
isotope in diese mineralien und in
methan aus den gesteinsporen daraufhin
im klartext heißt das also dass es in
einer tiefe bis zu rund 600 metern
bakterien gegeben haben muss die methan
abbaut zudem muss es welche gegeben
haben diese vater zu mieten reduzieren
das erdgas vorkommen unter dem
gigantischen krater in mittelschweden
könnte somit aber auch einen
biologischen ursprung haben bisher war
man eher von einem geochemischen
ursprung ausgegangen dazu heißt es in
der studie
die einschläge verursachen welche bis in
große tiefen und erzeugen damit poren
raum und die einschlags hitze treibt
hydrothermale kollektion an beides ist
günstig für tiefe ökosysteme und das
erinnert stark an im maß denn der nasa
rover curiosity hatte erst letztes herz
hat das 19 eine rekord hohe
methankonzentration in der mars luft
festgestellt messungen hatten außerdem
gezeigt dass die methankonzentration
dort das jahr über stark schwanken
ist das etwa ein beweis für biologische
aktivität auf dem roten planeten eine
deutsche forschungsgruppe hatte bereits
vor zwei jahren 2018 gezeigt dass aktive
zellverbände unter maß ähnlichen
bedingungen so lange überleben können
bis sie durch minimale wassermengen
wieder aktiviert werden außerdem hatten
die fachleute dann in einem experiment
nachgewiesen dass bestimmte mikroben in
salzhaltigen maß ähnlichen würden nicht
nur überleben sondern auch stoffwechsel
betreiben können die rede ist von den
sogenannten erschienen dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam in der studie
die niedrige durchschnittstemperatur und
wasser aktivität an der oberfläche des
mars machen
in organismen nicht leicht in dieser
umgebung zu bestehen oder gar sich
fortzupflanzen
doch die ergebnisse jüngerer
mars-mission zeigen dass die
umweltbedingungen zu bestimmten zeiten
und an bestimmten orten des roten
planeten durchaus die unteren grenzen
überschreitet die leben möglich machen
das mysteriöse methan auf dem mars
könnte demnach womöglich tatsächlich von
mikroben stammen
zurück zu dem schwedischen
forschungsteam dass europas größten
krater unter die lupe genommen hatte
die fachleute gehen davon aus dass die
mikroben erst nach dem abkühlen des
gesteins in den untergrund gefunden
haben das fazit der schwedische studie
ist jedenfalls mehr als spannend demnach
könnten einschlagskrater das entstehen
von mikroben gemeinschaften enorm
gefördert haben und zwar nicht nur auf
der erde sondern vielleicht auch auf dem
mars andere forschende dagegen gehen
nicht davon aus dass die bewohner des
erd- und grundes ursprünglich
oberirdisch gelebt haben sie vertreten
eine ganz andere these
und die ist nicht ohne demnach sind die
mikroben direkt im untergrund geboren
wurden handelt es sich also sogar um
eine unterirdische wiege des lebens und
ist das eine konkurrenz für die
sogenannte ursuppe in der frühen
geschichte der erde hatte der untergrund
tatsächlich bessere bedingungen für
leben geboten als die oberfläche unseres
planeten denn die atmosphäre fehlte die
strahlung aus dem weltraum gelangte
völlig ungehindert auf die erde und auch
zahlreiche vulkane und
meteoriteneinschläge machten das leben
auf der jungen erde eher ungemütlich
ganz anders dagegen im untergrund und so
sind manche forschenden davon überzeugt
dass der untergrund der erde der
ursprung allen lebens sein könnte
beweise gibt es dafür noch nicht und die
wissenschafts community weiß noch zu
wenig um diese mysteriösen rätsel an für
alle mal zu klären außerdem wissen
fachleute auch noch nicht im detail wie
genau das leben in der tiefe der erde
abläuft einen us forschungsteam hat
kürzlich herausgefunden dass das leben
in der tiefen biosphäre selbst für die
dortigen bewohner nicht wirklich
paradiesisch ist dazu der mikrobiologe
steven giovanni man gewinnt oft den
eindruck der tiefe untergrund seit
geradezu an garten eden für
mikroorganismen
unsere forschungsergebnisse zeigen
allerdings eher das gegenteil es sind
quasi biblische zustände die aber eher
an die hölle erinnern
das paradies das motto scheint sich ein
ganz anderes zu sein als beim
oberirdischen leben hier oben geht es
bei überleben vor allem auch darum zu
wachsen so die gängige meinung der
fachwelt über das leben auf der
erdoberfläche in der tiefen biosphäre
sieht das offensichtlich ganz anders aus
das zeigte eine analyse eines weiteren
us forschungsteams das 2,7 kilometer
tief gebohrt hatte die in dieser tiefe
aufgespürt mikroben waren nicht wirklich
gut dabei nur wenige zellen waren
überhaupt aktiv und anzeichen von
wachstum oder vermehrung konnten die
fachleute auch nicht entdecken dazu der
wissenschaftler tony fuchs der an dieser
studie beteiligt war
wir dachten immer alles muss wachsen um
überleben zu können aber wenngleich dies
für das leben auf der oberfläche zu
stimmen scheint ist es für bakterien in
extremen umgebungen offenbar kein
geeignetes motto was sie dort unten tun
ist nicht sehr viel
sie versuchen einfach nur durchzuhalten
es handelt sich also quasi um einen über
dauerzustand zu dem die zellen
offensichtlich durch die
rahmenbedingungen gezwungen werden der
mangel an licht und energiereichen
organischen molekülen sorgt also dafür
dass sich diese winzigen zellen nicht
einmal geteilt hatten in der studie
schreibt das forschungsteam dass sich
andere arten zwar durchaus vermehrt
hätten allerdings handelt es sich dabei
um eine durchschnittliche generation
zeit von achtung jahrhunderten bisher
tausenden der vergleich mit
oberirdischen einzeln macht deutlich wie
crazy das ist für viele mikroben die auf
der erdoberfläche leben ist es nicht
ungewöhnlich sich mehrmals innerhalb von
einer einzigen stunde zu teilen
eine andere studie bestätigt das
ergebnis dass das unterirdische leben
keineswegs paradiesisch ist die
fachleute hatten bohrkerne aus einer
tiefe von 500 metern unter dem
meeresboden genauer analysiert so
offenbarte sich das ernüchternde
ergebnis demnach gab es unter 100
bakterienzellen maximal eine die
anzeichen von leben zeigte manchmal war
sogar nur eine unter 100.000 dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam in seiner
studie die meisten der unterirdischen
mikroben im marinen sedimenten müssen
entweder an extrem niedrige stoffwechsel
aktivitäten angepasst sein oder tot was
genau in dieser tiefe vor sich geht ist
nach wie vor weitestgehend ungeklärt
doch möglicherweise kommen wir mit
dieser forschung zu unterirdischen leben
auch
dem außerirdischen leben irgendwann mal
auf die schliche außerirdische mega
zivilisation finden so könnte es gehen
anklicken anschauen und neugier zu
harmonieren hammer kanal bis dann bleibt
dran